PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video I want us to
work on the following problem.
A very shallow circular
reflecting pool
has uniform depth D and radius
R. And this is in meters.
And a disinfecting chemical
is released at its center.
After a few hours of
symmetrical diffusion outward,
the concentration at a point
little r meters from the center
is k over 1 plus r squared
grams per cubic meter.
The k here is a constant.
So we drop some chemical
into the middle of the pool.
And then it diffuses outward.
That's the idea there.
Now the question
is the following.
What amount of chemical
was released into the pool?
And obviously the
amount will be in grams.
Now to give you a
hint, probably you
want to draw a picture of this.
And then maybe
get some estimates
or some approximations
using shells.
Or you might just say,
you know, some strips,
some shells probably is
a better word for it.
And then you should
think about the fact
that, as you get better
and better estimates,
your approximation should
tend toward an integral.
So with that hint, I'll give you
a little time to work on this.
And when we come back,
I'll show you how I do it.
OK, welcome back.
Hopefully you were able
to make some headway.
And so let me start off by
doing what I asked you to do,
which is draw a picture.
Now the first picture
is fairly simple.
The first picture is my pool.
Right?
But that's not quite enough
to tell me some estimates.
But what do we have?
So the pool has radius
capital R and depth D.
And when I said we want to
do some approximation, what
I really meant is we
want to-- let me actually
get another color here-- we want
to say, take some fixed radius
out and assume that--
let me actually
draw this behind--
some fixed radius out,
and assume that the diffusion
is constant for some small bit.
Some small strip like this.
Which, actually, you notice
it's going to be rotated around.
Because all of this is relative
to distance from the center.
So, I'm hoping that
you can see kind
of what this drawing is doing.
Essentially what we
have here is if we
open that up, this blue
cylindrical shell is
approximately a piece-- oh it
doesn't quite look flat-- but,
a piece that looks
like-- oh well
we'll just stick with
that-- a little prism here.
So that's
approximately, if I were
to cut this blue cylindrical
shell here open and lay it
down flat, it would be
approximately a piece
kind of like this.
Right?
And so, what we're going
to do is estimate first
what amount of chemical
is released based
on pieces that look like this.
And then we're going to let
those pieces get very, very
narrow and get more
and more of them.
And this should remind
you of Riemann sums.
And how Riemann sums, as
you let the number of things
you're summing over
tend to 0-- sorry--
tend to infinity, so that
the little pieces are getting
narrower and narrower,
you're actually
going to end up
with an integral.
So this is where we're headed.
So let's just make sure
we understand kind of all
the pieces that are happening.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to take a bunch of
these cylinders,
and let's just determine
that we'll take n of them.
I shouldn't say cylinder.
Sorry, I should say shells.
We're going to take n of
these shell-type things.
So I'm going to say
the radii-- I'm going
to start with r_0 equals 0.
And I'm going to take
n different radii.
So r_0, r_1, up to--
sorry this is 0--
so r_n is equal to capital R.
So I guess I'm taking n plus 1,
but 0 is not really a radius.
But I have n
different partitions.
For each partition
of this big cylinder,
I get a piece like this.
Right?
I get a piece that,
when I open it up,
looks approximately like this.
Now, what I want
is a total amount.
I want grams.
Right?
And what I'm given-- if we come
back over here-- what I'm given
is the concentration
at a certain radius.
It's k over 1 plus r squared
grams per cubic meter.
Now, if nothing else, you should
have looked at this problem
and seen, well if I want
grams and I have something
in grams per cubic
meter, somewhere I'm
going to need something
with cubic meters
to cancel this unit,
so I end up with grams.
So if nothing else, then
maybe you can you can think,
oh I need to understand
volume of something
in order to solve this problem.
Right?
Now if we have n different
partitions-- so n shells--
that all started off as
this sort of blue-type thing
and I open up and
look like this.
Then I want to figure out what
is the volume of these shells.
Once I know the
volume of that shell,
I can figure out
the amount, roughly,
of chemical in that
piece by multiplying
by the concentration.
So let's figure out
what this volume is
in terms of these little
radii I'm looking at.
Well, when I open it
up, what do I get?
We're assuming this here is
this little segment here,
and so that's our delta r,
that's our change in radius.
That's how much I'm changing.
So this would be some r
subscript i and this would
be some r subscript i plus 1.
And let's assume that
we're taking everything
from the smaller radius.
We're going to do everything
So then, when I open
this up, this circle
is going to be my length.
So my length is 2 pi r sub i.
And then the height is easy.
The height is constant.
The height is just
capital D. Right?
So the volume of each shell--
let me come over here--
the volume of a shell is
something like 2 pi r sub i
times D times delta r.
And so then, the amount
of chemical in the shell
is going to be the volume
times the concentration.
Right?
The volume times
the concentration.
So the volume is, again, this.
I'm going to put the D
in front of the r sub i.
2 pi D r sub i delta r times
the concentration, which
if we come back over
here, the concentration is
k divided by 1 plus r squared
grams per cubic meter.
The r in this case
is the r sub i.
I'm assuming, because
I'm approximating
this, that everywhere
in the shell
has the same concentration,
has the concentration
of the interior radius.
So if we come back over here,
we're going to write k over 1
plus r sub i squared.
And now what do I do to estimate
the amount in the entire pool?
Well I add all of these up.
So let me come over
here and write down
what the sum will look like.
So I'm going to
be summing from i
equals-- I said I was
taking the interior radius,
I think-- i equals 0 to n
minus 1 of this quantity.
2*pi*D-- let me put the
k in there as well-- k.
And then r sub i over 1 plus
r sub i squared delta r.
So this is our
approximation of the amount
of chemical in the pool.
And again, we always want
to check and make sure.
I didn't write in any units,
but do the units make sense?
Well we know the
units make sense
because when I did the
amounts in the shell,
I did volume times
concentration.
And volume times concentration
is going to be in grams.
This is in cubic meters.
This is in grams
per cubic meter.
So I know I have the right unit.
So that's a good way to check.
It doesn't guarantee
you've done it correctly.
But at least you can check and
make sure you didn't do it,
you know that-- how
would I say this?
I would say that if the
units are not in grams,
you know you did
something wrong.
So at least now we know, OK,
it passes the first smell test.
Now what do I do to
find the exact value?
Well what I want
to do is, I want
to come back over to
the picture I have here
and I want to let these shells
get smaller and smaller.
And how do I let those shells
get smaller and smaller?
Narrower and narrower,
I should say.
I let them get
narrower by increasing
the number of radii on which
I do this kind of operation.
So I'm coming over
here and now I'm
letting the n get
bigger and bigger.
And as n gets bigger
and bigger, these values
are still determined
the same way.
But over here this n is
getting larger and larger.
So I can take the limit,
as n goes to infinity,
of this quantity to
get the exact amount.
What is the limit as n
goes to infinity of this?
This is actually an integral.
It's the integral
from 0 to capital R--
because my radius
is ranging from 0
to that big R-- of this
exact function of R. Right?
So I'm going to put
the 2*pi*D*k out here.
And then I get little
r over 1 plus r squared
and the delta r becomes our
dr. So this is, in fact,
going to be the amount, in
grams, of the chemical that
was released into the pool.
So we've set up our integral.
I think I'll stop here.
If you want to go further
and determine it, you can.
And you may want to think
about what strategy,
obviously, what strategy
you want to use in order
to solve this problem.
I'll give you a hint.
Maybe the best way
to solve this problem
is the fact that when you
take the derivative of 1
plus r squared, you
actually get 2r.
And so that derivative
is almost up here.
So maybe this is a good
hint to give you how you
would continue this problem.
But I'll stop there.
So let me just go
back one more time
and remind you
what we were doing.
What we were doing, if
we come back over here,
is we were given
a situation where
we knew a certain function
of the radius, the distance
from the center.
And we wanted to determine the
total amount of chemical that
was released into the pool.
And so we estimated.
We figured out a
way to estimate it
in terms of splitting
up the radii.
We had the radius
from 0 to big R.
And we just divided up the radii
and assumed certain things were
constant in these regions.
And we determined
the right function
to find-- if we move over here,
over here-- we would determine
the right function to find
the amount of chemical
in a certain shell, assuming
that the concentration was
constant throughout that shell.
And then, what we do is we know
that if we let those shells get
arbitrarily narrow,
that means that we're
letting the number of
radii over which we're
doing this go to infinity.
And we know that this
summation that we have here,
as n goes to infinity,
becomes an integral.
So that's really, we exploited
what we know about this sum
and letting this partition,
letting the delta
r get arbitrarily small.
That that, in the limit,
goes to an integral.
And then that's something we
can definitively calculate.
So I think I will stop there.